[Música]
estos aldeanos kurdos intentan impedir
que una empresa ponga una cantera de
mármol en su aldea en la provincia de
van al este de turquía las ráfagas que
se oyen son disparos al aire hechos por
el ejército turco con munición real los
casquillos encontrados en el suelo así
lo demuestran los soldados llevaron a
cabo esta fuerte intervención el 26 de
mayo para proteger la maquinaria de la
empresa minera en contra de los derechos
de los aldeanos según reportó nuestro
observador
[Música]
el día después del incidente todos
fuimos al pueblo con el colegio de
abogados de bani y el centro de derechos
humanos y conocimos a los aldeanos
esta manifestación era completamente
pacíficas de igual simplemente querían
impedir que la empresa minera destruyera
sus establos
su única fuente de ingresos
[Música]
la empresa no les notificó a los
aldeanos con antelación destruyeron 25
establos y 4 aldeanos fueron detenidos
fueron liberados al día siguiente
soy abogado de derechos humanos y he
vivido en esta zona durante muchos años
y nunca había visto un accidente como
ese
ahora vamos a presentar una denuncia en
nombre de las personas que fueron
detenidas por las fuerzas de seguridad
estos incidentes se producen en un
contexto muy tenso en esta región de
turquía el ejército está fuertemente
movilizado contra los rebeldes kurdos en
la provincia de ban incluso está
prohibido manifestarse desde el 2016
según las autoridades locales el
ejército realizó disparos al aire en
respuesta a las piedras que lanzaron los
aldeanos por su parte la empresa de
merkel inició este proyecto negó haber
participado en esta intervención vídeos
y sin un informe de evaluación del
impacto ambiental la empresa no puede
hacer nada para obtener ese informe
tienen que destruir esos establos y
michu
la empresa pero con las fuerzas de
seguridad no sabemos la relación que hay
detrás de esta historia millones de
lesiones
pero es posible que la empresa haya
sobornado a las fuerzas de seguridad
y este incidente también demuestra que
los habitantes de la provincia de vanos
no pueden disfrutar de sus derechos más
básicos ni siquiera pueden manifestarse
pacíficamente viven de canadá y su
disputa se somete
[Música]
a la misa más rápido que pierdan un buen
año
el gobierno iraní anunció cortes de luz
este verano para ahorrar electricidad
pero estos cortes han sido más largos y
frecuentes de lo esperado y en las redes
sociales los iraníes están expresando su
gran frustración miren eso hasta los
helados se están derritiendo tendré que
botarlo todo los semáforos no funcionan
no hay policía y los niños de la calle
que normalmente venden flores son los
que controlan el tráfico
nuestro vecino que tiene problemas
respiratorios se quedó encerrado en el
ascensor llamamos a los bomberos para
pedir ayuda los problemas más graves se
produjeron en el sector sanitario
algunas unidades de cuidados intensivos
se quedaron sin luz al igual que las
salas de urgencias y las morgues los
congeladores están a unos 45 grados en
el cuerpo se pudrió después de tres días
y ya no cabe en el auto funión y muerde
ya no pierde para saber más sobre este
tema hablamos con una doctora de un
hospital del noreste de irán quien desea
permanecer en el anonimato por razones
de seguridad
y los principales hospitales cuentan con
generadores de reserva para los equipos
esenciales pero si éstos no funcionan
durante uno de estos muchos cortes de
luz puede ser desastroso si es que eso
es lo que ocurrió en el quirófano de un
hospital de hispanos cuando se fue la
luz el generador no funcionó los
cirujanos tuvieron que terminar de
operar con la luz de sus celulares
durante estos apagones no podemos
utilizar herramientas de análisis médico
ni máquinas de rayos x para realizar
diagnósticos el gobierno de irán afirma
que las granjas de minado de bitcoin y
el calentamiento global son los
causantes del aumento del consumo de
electricidad pero los expertos en
energía aseguran que las causantes de
estos apagones serían más bien las
envejecidas infraestructuras iraníes
terminamos con esta historia que
conmovió a los usuarios de twitter y
linkedin el pasado 2 de junio un
profesor senegalés publicó dos fotos en
las que aparecía cargando a la bebé de
una de sus alumnas durante la clase nos
pusimos en contacto con este profesor la
vall y dubai quien nos explicó por qué
para él este es un gesto natural y cuál
era su intención al publicar estas
imágenes
el mensaje que quería mandarles a todas
las chicas a las mujeres que también son
estudiantes es mostrarles que la
maternidad y la educación superior no
son incompatibles si la chica que vino a
mi clase hubiera tenido la oportunidad
de dejar a su bebé con una niñera o en
una guardería no habría venido a clase
con él estamos en un país en el que hoy
en día hacen falta guarderías sobre todo
para la gente de ciertas clases sociales
y las guarderías tienen un precio que no
todas las mujeres y hombres pueden
costear y actualmente los estudiantes
suelen estar en una ciudad en khao lak o
en cualquier otra están solos sus padres
no están aquí hoy en día hay muchas
mujeres a las que el sistema ha
abandonado o ha rechazado simplemente
por estar embarazadas
hemos perdido mucho talento muchas
mujeres que podrían salvar el mundo a
las que el sistema ha rechazado porque
no podían conciliar maternidad y
estudios
si quieren escribir a nuestro equipo de
redacción todos nuestros contactos en
whatsapp facebook y twitter están en sus
pantallas envíen sus imágenes y tal vez
el próximo observador de france24 será
usted hasta pronto
[Música]